>> Tucker: SO THERE WAS A LOT
GOING ON OVER THE LAST ELECTION,
A LOT.
THE GROUP JUDICIAL WATCH HAS
OBTAINED HUNDREDS OF DOCUMENTS
FOR THE SECRETARY OF STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, THOSE DOCUMENTS
REVEAL THAT STATE OFFICIAL TO
PRESSURE THE SOCIAL MEDIA
COMPANIES, THE BIG ONES, GOOGLE,
TWITTER, FACEBOOK TO CENSOR
SOCIAL MEDIA POST THEY DIDN'T
LIKE AND THAT WOULDN'T HELP THEM
ABOUT THE 2020 ELECTION.
A STATE AGENCY SUCCESSFULLY
PRESSURED YOUTUBE TO BLOCK A
VIDEO ABOUT MAILING VOTING.
SOME OF THE STATES DOCUMENTS
WERE COMPILED BY THE FIRM, ITS
TOP CLIENT?
JOE BIDEN.
IF THE HOST OF RISING, HAPPY TO
HAVE MOM TONIGHT, YOU COULD BE A
FERVENT DIET AND VOTER AND STILL
THINK THAT MAYBE THIS LOOKS LIKE
THE END OF DEMOCRACY IN MY
OVERSTATING IT?
>> NO YOU'RE NOT.
YOUTUBE, AND MANY OF THESE WERE
BUILT ON THE BEDROCK PRINCIPLE
AND FREE SPEECH.
THIS IS WHAT YOU WOULD SEE IN
CHINA.
THE COMMUNIST CHINESE PARTY RUNS
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT WHICH ARE
THEN DISPERSED AT THE CHINESE
TECH COMPANIES WHO DECIDED THAT
OCEANA HAS ALWAYS BEEN AT WAR
WITH EAST ASIA OR EURASIA AND
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT THEY HAVE
COME TO LIVE WITH THEIR IN
CHINA.
THIS IS SOMETHING A ONE-PARTY
STATE LIKE CALIFORNIA IN
PARTICULAR FOR THE INTERTWINING
OF PARTY WITH THE GOVERNMENT AND
THE LARGE TECH COMPANIES WHO ARE
THEN LISTENING AND COMPLYING
WITH THESE REGULATIONS, LET'S
THINK ABOUT IT.
YOUR PREVIOUS GUESTS BROUGHT
THIS UP WHICH IS THAT DR. FAUCI
IN FEBRUARY WAS SAYING MASKS
DON'T WORK SO DOES THAT MEAN
YOUTUBE IN FEBRUARY SHOULD HAVE
BEEN TAKING DOWN VIDEOS IN WHICH
I AND SOME OTHER PEOPLE WERE
EXPRESSING SKEPTICISM AROUND
THIS?
THAT WOULD TECHNICALLY BE IN
VIOLATION OF GOVERNMENT PRACTICE
AND NOW THEY ARE DOING THE
OPPOSITE, THIS JUST GOES TO SHOW
HOW DYSTOPIAN THIS CAN GET VERY
QUICKLY.
>> Tucker: SURE.
GOOGLE IS SUPPRESSING THE
PHOTOGRAPHS OF THE GOVERNOR OF
VIRGINIA AND BLACKFACE WHICH
TELLS YOU A LOT SO IF YOU HAVE
THE MOST POWERFUL COMPANIES IN
THE WORLD WORKING SECRETLY TO
HELP A SPECIFIC POLITICAL PARTY,
THEN WHERE DOES THAT LEAVE
EVERYONE ELSE?
>> WHERE YOU GOING TO GO?
GREAT YOUR OWN GOOGLE?
THEY HAVE 90% OF SEARCH TRAFFIC.
THE MOST BEDROCK PRINCIPLE IS
WHEN YOU BEGIN TO SEE
INTERTWINING OF A POLITICAL
PARTY, OF STATE ENFORCEMENT AND
THEN ALONG WITH THE SO-CALLED
PRIVATE COMPANIES YOU LIVE IN AN
OLIGARCHY AND EVENTUALLY IN A
DICTATORSHIP AND THE ONLY WAY
THAT THEY CAN HAVE DISSENT AS IF
THEY HAVE TO CRUSH IT.
WE HAVE TWO OPTIONS.
WE ARE AMERICAN, LIBERTY IS IN
OUR BLOOD, LARGELY WHAT WE
SHOULD STRIVE FOR AND THE OTHER
OPTION IS A POLICE STATE AND
UNFORTUNATELY, THAT'S WHAT WE
ARE BEGINNING TO SEE.
>> Tucker: I HOPE A LOT OF
PEOPLE ARE HEARING HIM A